j'ai choisi des citrons qui viennent de
nice parce qu'ils sont très doux et cd
citron bio et qui ont un goût beaucoup
plus subtil que les citrons qu'on trouve
en général
au menu du jour la tarte au citron
meringuée le chef sylvie kemp leur
dispense ses cours de cuisine sucrée ou
salée
depuis décembre à plaisir que les gens
ont besoin d'apprendre les bases de la
cuisine et pour le groupe qui la rend
partie de découvrir la cuisine française
sur la table beurre sucre glace eux des
produits issus de l'agriculture
raisonnée voire bio et principalement de
producteurs locaux farine du moulin de
versailles beurre de grignon eu de
rambouillet la pâtisserie demande
précision et rigueur est pas un gramme
supplémentaire qui pourrait modifier la
structure du mais tout le monde refaire
près et avec plaisir les gens soient des
petits mails en disant j'ai réussi et ça
pour moi c'est la grande satisfaction
parce que pour moi la cuisine c'est
simple comme un jeu d'enfant et il faut
que ce soit facile à faire et je
démystifier beaucoup de choses dans mes
cours démystifier également la crème de
citron ou encore la meringue et enfin
chaque fois un petit menu
et voilà donc on part avec des produits
deux saisons qu'on peut tout de suite
reprendra la maison c'est aussi des
choses qu'on fait pas forcément
spontanément comme ça donc c'est
toujours sympa d'avoir un petit recettes
et 1
justement le fait d'avoir un guide pour
nous montrer un petit peu et placez au
four saupoudrer de sucre glace et vos
tartelette au citron meringuée sont
prêtes à être servi